Cédric, 30 ans, est sergent chef au 21ème Régiment
d'infanterie de marine.
- Pose, attendez, je ne peux pas être partout à la fois.
Là, je suis en cours de reconnaissance de 38,
donc deux minutes.
Aujourd'hui, il doit reprendre ce village tombé
entre les mains des insurgés.
Mais l'ennemi oppose une forte résistance.
- Ils sont chiants.
Ils arrivent à stopper la situation.
Ils arrivent à nous ralentir dans notre progression,
donc, c'est excessivement énervant.
- Quand on est en combat, Zone urbaine.
Pour l'emporter, ils pourront compter sur les conseils
de Miguel, un soldat rompu aux combats en zone urbaine
en Afrique et au Moyen-Orient.
- T'es pas mort ? Alors, continu, la guerre.
Parviendront-ils à rester en vie ?
Ce matin, Cédric, qui est en première ligne.
- Si vous avez visuel sur eux, ouverture du feu.
Engagé depuis plus de dix ans,
ce chef de groupe revient d'une opération en Afrique.
L'ennemi connaît les lieux par coeur.
Les soldats qui attaquent doivent être vigilants.
- Dans Bâtiment 05.
Actuellement, j'ai trois personnels vivants,
le restant du groupe est décédé.
À l'arrière des combats, dans son véhicule blindé,
le capitaine Éric note les pertes subies
et coordonne l'attaque de ses troupes.
- Bleu Écho. Est-ce que tu es en mesure de déclencher
un tir sur ce char, région Sud Espagne ?
Pour le commandant, la situation commence
à devenir préoccupante.
- Moi, ce que j'espère, c'est avoir le moins de pertes possible,
puisqu'à partir du moment où je perds des hommes,
la capacité des sections diminue et
donc, à partir de là, on n'est plus en mesure de remplir la mission.
Et en face, la force des adversaires est très bien organisée.
Selon les règles de l'armée française,
pour remporter une bataille en zone urbaine.
Il faut être au minimum six fois plus nombreux que l'adversaire.
Sans cela, l'avantage donné par le terrain est insurmontable.
Malgré cette écrasante supériorité numérique,
Cédric et son équipe sont mises en difficulté.
- Directe, ils savent où placer leurs appuis.
Ils savent où placer leurs fumigènes.
C'est vraiment, un ennemi très aguerri,
qui connaît très bien la zone.
D'où la difficulté pour nous de manœuvrer et de les surprendre.
- Ils sont battable ou pas ?
- Ils sont battable. Il y a la personne qui est imbattable.
Le truc, c'est d'arriver à retrouver la cendre.
Plus facile à dire qu'à faire.
- Ok, tu m'appuies, je vais monter.
Un, deux, trois.
Des soldats ne progressent presque jamais par les rues principales,
trop dangereuse.
Dès qu'ils le peuvent, ils passent de maison en maison
à travers des trous dans les murs.
Ils s'apprêtent à s'emparer du dernier bâtiment.
Sûr d'eux, trop sûr d'eux, l'offensive est un échec.
Cédric est indemne, mais beaucoup de soldats sont morts
ou gravement blessés.
- Quelle est votre capacité opérationnelle maintenant, à 17 heures ?
- Là, à l'heure actuelle, il me reste grosso modo une section.
Si je rassemble tous les éléments.